if it's getting a bit colder in your
part of the world this month you can
always cozy up with some video games if
you're a PlayStation Plus subscriber and
want to know what you can play for free
in October I've got you covered and good
news for all you scaredy cats out there
only one of these is a horror game the
first ps4 game this month is a biggie
it's Metal Gear Solid 5 the phantom pain
call it an intrical call it the series
finale but whatever you call it there
are tons of missions for you to play
through your way you can go in guns
blazing take the stealthy approach or
carve your own path across the deserts
and jungles ps4 is also getting amnesia
collection which includes the Dark
Descent and a machine for pigs
if being chased or hiding from monsters
is what freaks you out well that's
basically a hundred percent of what
these games are but hey if you're
looking to get into that Halloween
spirit
this is your best bet additionally the
psvr exclusive rigs will be free to PS
Plus members until November 7th
if you've never played the competitive
mech combat game before you've got
plenty of time to try it out hopefully
your competitive spirit outweighs any
motion sickness ps3 players can rev up
with Monster Jam battlegrounds not to be
confused with the ever-popular player on
knowns battlegrounds this puts you in
the seat of the most famous monster
trucks letting you blast through plenty
of Stadium events and special stunts if
you prefer something more methodical you
can also try out hustle Kings on ps3 to
prove your pool skills to the masses you
can take the competition online and if
you need to practice a bit first
there are also career and trickshot
modes to dive into on the Vita side you
can get your hands on Hugh as the name
implies this platformer is all about
color letting you change the colour of
the background to make any obstacles
fade away there's a pretty emotional
story behind all the palette swapping
too and finally let's get some aerial
combat going with Sky Force anniversary
this shoot-'em-up is a few years past
the 10 year anniversary it celebrated
but there's still plenty of power-ups to
grab and bosses to take down and thanks
to cross by both Sky Force and Hugh can
also be played on ps4
and those are your free PS plus games
for October they'll go live on the PSN
store on Tuesday October 3rd remember
you can always check out gameplay clips
and reviews for these titles over at
games spot and if you want to keep up
with all of our top stories you can grab
the official game spot now app on iOS
and Android
[Music]